what you were looking at right now is
something called quaternion
multiplication or rather you're looking
at a certain representation of a
specific motion happening on a
four-dimensional sphere being
represented in our three-dimensional
space one which he'll understand by the
end of this video
quarter neons are an absolutely
fascinating and often underappreciated
number system from math just as complex
numbers are a two-dimensional extension
of the real numbers quaternions
are a four dimensional extension of
complex numbers but they're not just
playful mathematical shenanigans they
have a surprisingly pragmatic utility
for describing rotation in three
dimensions and even for quantum
mechanics the story of their discovery
is also quite famous in math the Irish
mathematician William Rowan Hamilton
spent much of his life seeking a three
dimensional number system analogous to
the complex numbers and as the story
goes his son would ask him every morning
whether or not he had figured out how to
divide triples and he would always say
no not yet
but on October 16th 1843 while crossing
the Broome bridge in Dublin he realized
what they supposed flash of insight that
what he needed was not to add a single
dimension to the complex numbers but to
add two more imaginary dimensions three
imaginary dimensions describing space
and the real numbers sitting
perpendicular to that in some kind of
fourth dimension he carved the crucial
equation describing these three
imaginary units into the bridge which
today bears a plaque in his honor
showing that equation now you have to
understand our modern notion of vectors
with their dot product and the cross
product and things like that didn't
really exist in Hamilton's time at least
not in a standardized form so after his
discovery he pushed hard for Quattro
neons to be the primary language with
which we teach students to describe
three-dimensional space even forming an
official quaternion society to
proselytize his discovery now
unfortunately this was balanced with
mathematicians on the other side of the
fence who believed that the confusing
notion of quaternion multiplication was
not necessary for describing three
dimensions resulting in some truly
hilarious old-timey trash-talk
legitimately calling them evil
it's even believed that the Mad Hatter
scene from Alice in Wonderland whose
author you may know was an Oxford
mathematician was written in reference
to quaternions that the chaotic table
placement changes were mocking their
multiplication and that certain quotes
were referencing their non commutative
nature fast forward about a century and
the computing industry gave quaternions
a resurgence among programmers who work
with graphics and robotics and anything
involving orientation in 3d space and
this is because they give an elegant way
to describe and compute 3d rotations
which is computationally more efficient
than other methods and which also avoids
a lot of the numerical errors that arise
in these other methods the 20th century
also brought quaternion some more love
from a completely different direction
quantum mechanics you see the special
actions the quaternions described in
four dimensions are actually quite
relevant to the way the two-state
systems like spin of an electron or the
polarization of a photon are described
mathematically what I'll show you here
is a way to visualize quaternions in
their full four-dimensional glory it
would surprise me if this approach was
fully original but I can say that it's
certainly not the standard way to teach
pattern eons
and that the specific four-dimensional
right-hand-rule image that I'd like to
build up to is something that I haven't
really seen elsewhere building up an
understanding for this visual will take
us meaningful time but once you have it
there is a very natural and satisfying
intuition for how to think about
quaternion multiplication it won't be
until the next video that I show you how
exactly quarter neons describe
orientation in three dimensions which is
for some people the whole reason we care
about it but once we're able to go at it
armed with the image of what they're
doing to a 4d hyper sphere there's a
pleasing understanding to be had for the
otherwise opaque formulas characterizing
this relationship
the structure here will be to start by
imagining teaching complex numbers to
someone who only understands one
dimension then describing 3d rotations
to someone who only understands two
dimensions and ultimately to represent
what quaternions are doing up in four
dimensions within the constraints of our
3d space
our first character is Linus the line
Lander whose mind can only grasp the one
dimensional geometry of lines in the
algebra of real numbers we're gonna try
to describe complex members to Linus and
it's really important for you to
empathize with him as much as you can
during this because in a few minutes
you're gonna be in his shoes on the one
hand you could define complex numbers
purely algebraically you say each one is
expressed as some real number plus some
other real number times I where pi is a
newly invented constant whose defining
property is that I times I equals
negative one then you say to Linus to
multiply two complex numbers you just
use the distributive property what many
people learn in school is foil
and you apply this rule that I times I
equals negative one to simplify things
down further and that's fine that
totally works in the standard textbook
way to introduce Quattro neons is
analogous to this showing the algebraic
rules and calling it done but I think
something is missing if we don't at
least try to show Linus the geometry of
complex numbers then what complex
multiplication looks like since the
problems in math and physics we're
complex numbers are shockingly useful
often leverage this spatial intuition
you and I who understand two dimensions
might think of it like this when you
multiply two complex numbers Z times W
you can think of Z as a sort of function
acting on W rotating and stretching it
in some way I like to think of this by
broadening the view and asking what does
he do to the entire plane and you can
think of that bird's-eye view action by
imagining using one hand to fix the
number 0 in place and using another hand
to drag the point at 1 up to Z since
anything times 0 is 0 and anything times
1 is itself and in two dimensions there
is one and only one stretching rotating
action on the plane that'll do this this
is also how I'll have you thinking about
quaternion multiplication later on where
the number on the Left acts as a kind of
function to the one on the right and
we'll understand this function by seeing
how it acts by transforming space
although instead of rotating 2d space it
does a sort of double rotation in 4d
space
by the way if you want to review
thinking about complex numbers as a kind
of action a good warm-up for this video
might be the one I did on e to the PI I
explained with introductory goop theory
now line is the line Lander is pretty
comfortable with the idea of stretching
that's what multiplication by real
numbers looks like maybe it's a little
weird for him to think about stretching
in multiple dimensions but it's not
fundamentally different the difficult
thing to communicate to Linus is
rotation specifically focus on the unit
circle of the complex plane all the
numbers a distance one from zero since
multiplication by these numbers
corresponds to pure rotation how would
you explain to Linus the look and the
feel of multiplying by these numbers at
first that might seem impossible I mean
rotation is just such an intrinsically
two-dimensional idea but on the other
hand rotation involves only one degree
of freedom a single number the angle
specifies a given rotation uniquely so
in principle it should be possible to
associate the set of all rotations to
the one dimensional continuum that is
Linus's world and there are many ways
you could do this but the one I'm going
to show you is what's called a
stereographic projection it's a special
way to map a circle onto a line or a
sphere into a plane or even a 4d hyper
sphere into 3d space
for every point on the unit circle draw
a line from negative 1 through that
point and wherever it intersects the
vertical line through the circle Center
that's where the point of the circle
gets projected
so for example the point of one gets
projected into the center of the line
the point I actually stays fixed in
place as does negative I
all of the points on that 90-degree arc
between one and I will get projected
somewhere in the interval between where
one landed and where I landed
as you continue farther around the
circle on the arc between I and negative
one the projected points end up farther
and farther away at an increasing rate
similarly if you come around the other
way towards negative one the projected
points end up farther and farther on the
other end of the line this line of
projected points is what we show to
Linus labeling a few key points like 1
and I and negative 1 all for reference
technically the point at negative 1 has
no projection under this map since the
tangent line to the circle at that point
never crosses the vertical line but what
we say is that negative 1 ends up at the
point at infinity this is a special
point you imagine adding to the line
where you would approach it if you walk
infinitely far along the line in either
direction now it's important to remember
and to remind Linus that what he's
seeing is only the complex numbers that
are a distance 1 from the origin the
unit circle
Linus doesn't see most numbers like 0 or
1 plus I or negative 2 minus I but
that's okay because right now we just
want to describe complex numbers Z we're
multiplying by Z has the effect of a
pure rotation so he only needs to
understand the unit circle
for example when we take the number I
and multiply it by any other complex
number W the effect is to rotate by 90
degrees counterclockwise and when we
apply this action to the circle being
projected down to the line for Linus
what does he see well it's a bit of a
strange morphing action on the line one
which I want you to become familiar with
for something we'll see you later on
it's easiest to understand by following
a few key reference points I times 1 is
I so that means the number 1 should move
up to I I times I is negative 1 so the
point at I slides off to infinity
I times negative 1 is equal to negative
I so that point at infinity kind of
comes back around from the bottom to the
position one unit below the center and I
times negative I is 1 so that point at
negative I slides up to 1 even though
this is kind of a weird motion it lets
us communicate some important ideas to
Linus
for example multiplying by I 4 times
which corresponds to rotating by 90
degrees four times in a row gets us back
to where we started I to the fourth
equals one here to get more of a feel
for things let me just show the circle
rotated at various different angles on
both the left and the right half of the
screen here and putting a hand on the
point that started at the number one to
help us and to help Linus keep track of
the overall motion
[Music]
next let's introduce Felix the
flatlander who only understands
two-dimensional geometry imagine trying
to explain rotations of a sphere to
Felix in the spirit of transitioning
from complex numbers to quaternions
let's extend the complex numbers with
its horizontal axis of real numbers and
its vertical axis of imaginary numbers
with a third axis defined by some newly
invented constant J sitting one unit
away from zero perpendicular to the
complex plane instead of having this new
axis in the z direction like you might
expect for a better analogy with how
well visualize quaternions we'll want to
orient things so that the I and the J
axes sit in the X and the y directions
with the real number line aligned along
the z direction so every point in 3d
space is described as some real number
plus some real number times I plus some
real number times J as it happens it's
not possible to define a notion of
multiplication for a 3d number system
like this that would satisfy the usual
algebraic properties that make
multiplication a useful construct
perhaps all outline why this is the case
in a follow-on video but staying focused
on our current goal think about
describing 3d rotations in this
coordinate system to Felix the
flatlander the unit sphere consists of
all those numbers which are a distance
one from zero at the origin meaning the
sum of the squares of their coordinates
is one we can't show all of 3d space to
Felix but what we can do is project this
2d surface to him and give him a feel
for what reorientation of the sphere
looked like under that projection
analogous to what we did before
stereographic projection will associate
almost every point on the unit sphere
with a unique point on the horizontal
plane defined by the I in the J axes for
each point on the sphere draw a line
from negative 1 at the South Pole
through that point and see where it
intersects the plane
so the point one at the North Pole ends
up at the center of the plane all of the
points of the Northern Hemisphere get
mapped somewhere inside the unit circle
of the IJ plane and that unit circle
which passes through IJ negative I and
negative J actually stays fixed in place
and that's an important point to make
note of even though most points and
lines and patches that Felix the
flatlander sees are going to be Warped
projections of the real sphere this unit
circle is the one thing that he has
which is an honest part of our unit
sphere unaltered by projection all of
the points in the southern hemisphere
get projected outside that unit circle
each getting farther and farther away as
you approach negative one at the South
Pole and again negative one has no
projection under this mapping but what
we say is that it ends up at some point
at infinity that point at infinity is
something such that no matter which
direction you walk on the plane as you
go infinitely far out you'll be
approaching that point it's analogous to
how if you walk any direction away from
the North Pole you're approaching the
South Pole now let me just pull up a
view of what Felix sees in two
dimensions as I rotate the sphere in
various ways the lines of latitude and
longitude drawn on that sphere get
projected into various circles and lines
in Felix's space and the way I've done
things up here the checkerboard pattern
on the surface of the sphere is
accurately reflected in the projected
view that you see with Felix and the
pink dot represents where the point that
started at the North Pole ends up after
the rotation and that yellow circle
represents where the Equator ended up
after the projection the more you put
yourself in Felix's shoes right now
the easier quarter neons will be in a
moment and as with Linus it helps to
focus on a few key reference objects
rather than trying to see the whole
sphere this circle passing through one
eye negative 1 and negative eye gets
mapped onto a line which Felix sees as
the horizontal axis it's important to
remind Felix that what he sees is not
the same thing as the IX
remember we're only projecting the
numbers that have a distance 1 from the
origin so most points on the actual I
axis like 0 & 2 I and 3i etcetera are
completely invisible to Felix
similarly the circle that passes through
1j negative 1 and negative J gets
projected onto what he sees as a
vertical line and in general any line
that Felix sees comes from some circle
on the sphere that passes through
negative 1 in some sense a line is just
a circle that passes through the point
at infinity now think about what Felix
sees as we rotate the sphere a 90 degree
rotation about the J axis brings one to
I I to negative 1 negative 1 to negative
I and negative I to 1 so what Felix the
flatlander sees is an extension of the
rotation that line is the line lander
was seeing notice also that this action
rotates the I J unit circle to the
position where the 1 J unit circle used
to be so what Felix sees is his yellow
unit circle getting transformed into a
vertical line while that red vertical
line gets transformed into the unit
circle of course from our perspective we
know this is all just rigid motion no
actual stretching or more thing is
taking place all of that is just an
artifact of the projection similarly a
rotation about the I axis involves
moving 1 2 j j 2 negative 1 negative 1
to negative J and negative J 2 1 this
rotation turns the I J unit circle into
the 1i unit circle which to Felix looks
like the unit circle getting transformed
into a horizontal line
a rotation about the real axis is
actually quite easy for Felix to
understand since the whole projection
simply gets rotated about the origin
where the only point staying fixed in
place are one at the origin and negative
one off at infinity in the same way that
the complex numbers included the real
numbers with a single extra
quote-unquote imaginary dimension
represented by the unit I and that the
not actually a number system thing we
had in three dimensions included a
second imaginary direction J the
quaternions include the real numbers
together with three separate imaginary
dimensions represented by the unit's I J
and K each of these three imaginary
dimensions is perpendicular to the real
number line and they're all
perpendicular to each other somehow so
in the same way that complex numbers are
represented as a pair of real numbers
each quaternion
can be written using four real numbers
and it lives in four-dimensional space
you often think of this as being broken
up into a real or scalar part and then a
3d imaginary part and Hamilton used a
special word for quaternions that had no
real part and just ijk components a word
which was previously somewhat foreign in
the lingo of math and physics vector on
the one hand you could just define
quaternion multiplication by giving the
rules for how I J and K multiplied
together and saying that everything must
distribute nicely this is analogous to
defining complex multiplication by
saying that I times I is negative 1 and
then distributing and simplifying
products and indeed this is how you
would tell a computer to perform
quaternion multiplication and the
relative compactness of this operation
compared to say matrix multiplication is
what's made quaternion so useful for
graphics programming and many other
things there's also a rather elegant
form of this multiplication rule written
in terms of the dot product and the
cross product and in some sense
quaternion multiplication subsumes both
of these notions at least as they appear
in three dimensions
but just as a deeper understanding for
complex multiplication comes from
understanding its geometry that
multiplying by a complex number involves
a combination of scaling and rotating
you and I are here for the four
dimensional geometry of quaternion
multiplication and just as the magnitude
of a complex number its distance from
zero is the square root of the sum of
the squares of its component that same
operation gives you the magnitude of a
quaternion and multiplying 1/4 nyan q1
by another q2 has the effect of scaling
q2 by the magnitude of q1 followed by a
very special type of rotation in four
dimensions and those special 4d
rotations the heart of what we need to
understand correspond to the hyper
sphere of quaternions a distance 1 from
the origin both in the sense that the
quaternions whose multiplying action is
a pure rotation live on that hyper
sphere and in the sense that we can
understand this weird 4d action just by
following points on the hyper sphere
rather than trying to look at all of the
points in the inconceivable stretch as a
four dimensional space analogous to what
we did for Linus and Felix we
stereographically project this hyper
sphere into 3d space
[Music]
this label in the upper right is going
to show a given unit quaternion and this
little pink dot will show where that
particular quaternion gets projected in
our 3d space just as before we're
projecting from the number negative one
which sits on the real number line that
is somehow perpendicular to all of our
3d space and beyond our perception just
as before the number one ends up
projected straight into the center of
our space and in the same way that I and
negative I were fixed in place for Linus
and that the IJ unit circle was fixed in
place for Felix we get a whole sphere
passing through I J and K on that unit
hyper sphere which stays in place under
the projection so what we see is a unit
sphere in our 3d space represents the
only unaltered part of the hyper sphere
of quaternions
getting projected down on to us it's
something analogous to the equator of a
3d sphere and it represents all of the
unit quaternions whose real part is zero
what Hamilton would have described as
unit vectors the unit quaternions with
positive real parts between 0 & 1 end up
somewhere inside this unit sphere closer
to the number 1 in our 3d space which
should feel analogous to how the
Northern Hemisphere got mapped inside
the unit circle for Felix on the other
hand all the unit quaternions with
negative real part end up somewhere
outside that unit sphere
the number negative one is sitting off
at the pointed infinity which you can
easily find by walking in any direction
keep in mind even though we see the
projection of some of these Quatro neons
as being closer or farther from the
origin of our 3d space everything you're
looking at represents a unit quaternion
so everything you're looking at really
has the same magnitude the same distance
from the number zero and that number
zero itself is nowhere to be found in
this picture like all other non unit
quaternions it's invisible to us in the
same way that for Felix the circle
passing through one eye negative one and
negative I got projected into a line
through the origin when we see this line
through the origin passing through I and
negative I we should understand that it
really represents a circle likewise upon
the hyper sphere invisible to us there
is a unit sphere passing through one I J
negative one negative I and negative J
and that whole sphere gets projected
into the plane that we see passing
through one i- i j- j and negative one
off at infinity what you and i might
call the XY plane in general any plane
that you see here really represents the
projection of a sphere somewhere up on
the hyper sphere which passes through
the number negative one now the action
of taking a unit quaternion and
multiplying it by any other quaternion
from the left can be thought of in terms
of two separate 2d rotations happening
perpendicular to and in sync with each
other in a way that could only ever be
possible in four dimensions as a first
example let's look at multiplication by
I we already know what this does to the
circle that passes through one and I
which we see as a line
one goes to I I goes to negative one off
at infinity negative one comes back
around to negative I and negative I goes
to one remember just like what lino saw
all of this is the stereographic
projection of a 90 degree rotation now
look at the circle passing through J and
K which is in a sense perpendicular to
the circle passing through one and I now
it might feel weird to talk about two
circles being perpendicular to each
other especially when they have the same
center the same radius and they don't
touch each other at all but nothing
could be more natural in four dimensions
you can think of the action of I on this
perpendicular circle as obeying a
certain right hand rule if you'll excuse
the intrusion of my ghostly green screen
hand into our otherwise pristine
platonic mathematical stage you let that
thumb of your right hand point from the
number 1 to I and you curl your fingers
the JK circle will rotate in the
direction of that curl how much well by
the same amount as the one I circle
rotates which is 90 degrees in this case
this is what I meant by two rotations
perpendicular to and in sync with each
other so J goes to K K goes to negative
J
negative J goes to negative K and
negative K goes to J this gives us a
little table for what the number I does
to the other quaternions but I want this
not to be something that you memorize
but something that you could close your
eyes and you could really see
computationally if you know what a
quaternion does to the numbers 1 IJ and
K you know what it does to any arbitrary
quaternion since multiplication
distributes nicely in the language of
linear algebra 1 I J and K form a basis
of our four dimensional space so knowing
what our transformation does to them
gives us the full information about what
it does to all of space geometrically a
four dimensional creature would be able
to look at those two perpendicular
rotations that I just described and
understand that they lock you into one
and only one rigid motion for the hyper
sphere we might lack the intuitions of
such a hypothetical creature but we can
maybe try to get close here's what the
action of repeatedly multiplying by I
looks like on our stereographic
projection of the ijk sphere it gets
rotated into what we see as a plane then
gets rotated further back to where it
used to be though the orientation is all
reversed now then it gets rotated again
into what we see as a plane and after
the fourth iteration it ends up right
back where it started as another example
think of a quaternion like q equals
negative square root of 2 over 2 plus
square root of 2 over 2 times i which if
we pull up a picture of a complex plane
is a 135 degree rotation away from 1 in
the direction of i under our projection
we see this along the line from 1 to i
somewhere outside the unit sphere if
that sounds weird just remember how
linus would have seen the same number
the action of multiplying this Q by all
other quarter neons
will look to us like dragging the point
at 1 all the way to this projected
version of Q while the JK circle gets
rotated 135 degrees according to our
right-hand rule
multiplication by any other quaternion
is completely similar for example let's
see what it looks like for Jay to act on
other quaternions by multiplication from
the left the circle through 1 + J which
we see projected as a line through the
origin gets rotated 90 degrees
dragging 1 up to J so J times 1 is 1 + J
times J is negative 1 the circle
perpendicular to that 1 passing through
I and K gets rotated 90 degrees
according to this right-hand rule where
you point your thumb from 1 to J so J
times I is negative K and J times K is I
in general for any other unit quaternion
you see somewhere in space start by
drawing the unit circle passing through
1 Q and negative 1 which we see in our
projection as a line through the origin
then draw the circle perpendicular to
that one on what we see as the unit
sphere you rotate the first circle so
that one ends up where Q was and rotate
the perpendicular circle by the same
amount according to the right hand rule
one thing worth noticing here is that
order of multiplication matters it's not
as mathematicians would say commutative
for example I times J is K which you
might think of in terms of I acting on
the quaternion J rotating it up to K but
if you think of J is acting on I J times
I it rotates I to negative K in fact
commutativity this ability to swap the
order of multiplication is a way more
special property than a lot of people
realize and most groups of actions on
some space don't have it it's like how
in solving a rubik's cube order matters
a lot
or how rotating a cube about the z axis
and then about the x axis gives a
different final state from rotating it
about the x axis then about the z axis
and last as one final but rather
important point so far i've shown you
how to think about quaternions as acting
by left multiplication where when you
read an expression like i times j you
think of i as a kind of function
morphing all of space and j is just one
of the points that it's acting on but
you can also think of them as a
different sort of action by multiplying
from the right where in this expression
j would be acting on i in that case the
rule for multiplication is very similar
it's still the case that one goes to j
and j goes to negative 1 etc but instead
of applying the right-hand rule to the
circle perpendicular to the 1j circle
you would use your left hand so either
way i times j is equal to k but you can
either think about this with your right
hand curling the number j to the number
k as your thumb points from 1 to i or as
your left hand curling I to K as it's
thumb points from 1 to J understanding
this left hand rule for multiplication
from the other side will be extremely
useful for understanding how unit
quaternions describe rotation in three
dimensions and so far it's probably not
clear how exactly quarter neons do
describe 3d rotation I mean if you
consider one of these actions on the
unit sphere passing through I J and K it
doesn't leave that sphere in place it
morphs it out of position so the way
that this works is slightly more
complicated than a single quaternion
product
it involves a process called conjugation
and I'll make a full follow-on video all
about it so that we have the time to go
through some examples in the meantime
for more information on the story of
quaternions and their relation to
orientation in 3d space quanta a
mathematical publication I'm sure a lot
of you are familiar with just put out a
post in a kind of loose conjunction with
this video link in the description if
you enjoyed this consider sharing it
with some friends and if you felt like
the narrative structure here was
actually helpful for understanding maybe
reassure those friends who would be
turned off by a large timestamp that
good math is actually worth the time and
many thanks to the patrons among you I
actually spent way longer than I care to
admit on this project so your patience
and support is especially appreciated
this time around
[Music]
you